Hi.
My name is Reto Meier.
I'm the tech lead for the
Android Developer Relations
team at Google.
And I'm here to dig beneath
the delicious chocolate
shell of the latest
flavor of Android,
and into the
wafer-biscuity goodness
at the center of the
new developer features.
KitKat may only represent a
0.1 increase in version number,
but it turns out that
a small bump can still
include a lot of new features.
Where the defining
characteristic of Jelly Bean
was buttery
smoothness, KitKat is
all about memory optimization.
Android 4.4 is designed
to run just as smoothly
on a much broader range of
devices, including those
with as little as
512 megs of RAM.
For developers, that means a
selection of new APIs and tools
to help us ensure
that our apps are
as memory efficient
as the platform.
You can start by checking if
your app is running on a memory
constrained device using
the new .isLowRamDevice call
on the ActivityManager.
Based on the result,
you might choose
to modify or even
disable features
with significant
memory implications
to ensure your app
provides a great user
experience on devices
with memory limits
similar to those featured
by Guy Pearce's character
in "Memento."
Of course, disabling features
is always a last resort,
so check out this guide for
tips on how you can optimize
your app's memory
usage without having
to sacrifice functionality.
But before you can start
improving your app's memory
efficiency, you need
to first understand
how you're using memory
in the first place.
The new procstats tool helps
you analyze memory resources,
providing data about app's
execution durations and memory
use.
You can access procstats
from the adb tool by calling,
adb shell dumpsys procstats.
If command lines make
you nervous, fear not.
Android 4.4 also includes
a new developer option
that helps you analyze
your app's memory
profile on any
Android 4.4 device
or emulator through the Process
Stats developer option screen.
Below the system
memory summary, there's
a list of blue bars indicating
the relative computed memory
load of each app's process,
and the relative percentage
of time each has spent
in the background.
Selecting that displays a
summary of the memory consumed
and the percentage of
the collection interval
that this particular app
has been running for,
as well as the average
and maximum RAM usage.
It's not all about memory
efficiency, though.
KitKat also includes some new
ways to build beautiful apps,
starting with some updates
to the Android Design Guide,
designed to help
you create striking,
innovative, and
distinctive apps that
offer users a
magical experience.
For more details, check
out tomorrow's episode
of "Android Design in Action."
In terms of APIs,
there's support
for a more immersive full-screen
experience, a new transition
framework for animating scenes,
closed captioning support,
and a new tool for
high-fidelity screen recording.
The new full-screen
immersive mode
lets you create full-bleed UIs
that reach from edge to edge,
hiding all system UI, including
the status and navigation bars.
It allows your app to
respond to touch events
from areas that would otherwise
be occupied by the system bars.
It's a great solution for rich,
visual content such as photos,
videos, maps, books, and games.
You can enable
this new mode using
two new mutually
exclusive system UI
flags-- immersive
and immersive_sticky.
This code shows how
to toggle between
an immersive full-screen
experience within your app
using the Immersive flag.
Alternatively, you can utilize
the immersive_sticky flag
to create a persistent,
immersive experience
that will automatically
rehide the system
bars after a short delay,
or if the user interacts
with the middle of the screen.
You can learn more
about the new immersive
modes, including
the best practices
for using each alternative, in
Roman Nurik's Immersive Mode
DevByte.
To make it easier to create
high-quality animations
in your app, Android 4.4 also
introduces a new transitions
framework for animating
between scenes.
Now it's pretty common
to use animations
to help users understand their
progress through UI states
where each state can
expose different actions.
The new transitions framework
helps you define these scenes--
typically view hierarchies like
these-- and the transitions
which define how to animate the
transformations between scenes
when the user enters
or exits them.
You can use one of several
pre-defined transition types
based on specific
properties like layout
bounds or visibility, or
use the auto-transition type
to automagically fade,
move, and resize views
during a scene change.
You can also define
custom transitions
that animate the properties
that matter most to your app,
or even plug in your
own animation styles.
For more details, check
out the Transitions DevByte
by our master of
animation, Chet Haase.
In an effort to make your
apps more accessible,
Android 4.4 includes
system-wide preferences
for closed captioning.
Users can now set global
captioning preferences,
and apps that use video can
use those settings to adjust
how they present closed captions
by using the new Captioning
Manager.
Apps that use
VideoView can simply
pass a captioning
stream in WebVTT format,
along with the video
stream for rendering.
And the system will handle
display of the captions
according to those
user preferences.
For more details, check out
this DevByte by Alan Viverette,
the engineer who
implemented it all.
If you've ever tried to
record a demo of your app
by holding a video
camera very steady,
you'll appreciate the
new screen recording
tool that lets you capture
video as you use the device
and store it as an MP4.
You can record in any
device-supported resolution
and bit rate, and
the output retains
the aspect ratio of the display.
You can access screen recording
through the adb tool calling
adb shell screenrecord,
or through the DDMS
panel in Eclipse
or Android Studio.
KitKat also includes a couple
of significant new storage API
changes, with a new
storage access framework
and a fully supported
SMS content provider.
The new storage
access framework makes
it easier for users to browse
and open documents, images,
and other files across all
of the available local and
cloud-based document
storage providers.
If you develop an app
that manages files or uses
documents, you can integrate
with the storage access
framework using
the create_document
or open_document
intents, and the system
will display the
standard UI, including
content from all the
available document providers.
If you want to add
a storage provider,
you implement a new
documents provider.
Overriding these
four methods will
let you manage the browsing,
reading, and writing
of any local or remote data that
can be represented as files.
Then, you just need to
add the documents provider
manifest intent filter,
and request permission
to manage documents.
This process will register
your provider with the storage
access framework and make it
available to the standard UI.
Then, whenever your
app is installed,
any app that uses this framework
to view or select files
will provide access
to your content.
Our very own Lisa
Wray has created
DevBytes for both provider and
consumer uses of the storage
access framework, so check
them out for more details.
Now, if you've been using
undocumented methods
to provide an SMS-based app,
now is an excellent opportunity
to familiarize yourself with the
official APIs for SMS handling.
That primarily involves a
newly documented SMS content
provider, but also
introduces new semantics
for receiving messages and
writing to the provider.
When a message is
received, the system
routes it directly to the
user's default messaging app
using the SMS_DELIVER
intent, while other apps
can continue to listen for
incoming messages using the SMS
Received intent.
Only the default app is able to
write new messages to the SMS
provider, but other apps can
continue to read from it.
Apps that aren't
the current default
can also continue
to send messages.
Here, the system will write
those outgoing messages
to the provider on your
behalf, so that users can still
see them in their default app.
For more details, check
out Adam's DevByte.
Also included in
Android 4.4 are a number
of additions to help your app
interact with the real world,
including new Bluetooth profiles
for Bluetooth HID Over GATT,
which provides apps
with a low latency
link for low-power peripheral
devices like mice, joysticks,
and keyboards, and Bluetooth
MAP for nearby device message
exchange.
There's also new platform
support for built-in IR
blasters with a
new API that lets
you check whether the device
has an infrared emitter,
query its carrier frequencies,
and then send infrared signals.
There's also support
for host card emulation.
HCE adds support for secure
NFC-based transactions
for things like payments,
loyalty programs, card access,
and transit passes
by allowing your app
to emulate an NFC
smart card, though
without requiring a
provisioned secure element.
It also supports
a new reader mode
to have your app act
as a reader for HCE
cards and other
NFC-based transactions.
Android HCE emulates ISO
7816-based smart cards
using the ISO 14443-4
protocol for transmission,
along with the application
identifiers as defined
in ISO 7816-4 as the basis
for routing transactions
to the correct
Android applications.
There's also native platform
support for printing,
along with APIs for
managing printing
over Wi-Fi or
cloud-hosted services
such as Google Cloud Print.
You can use these new APIs
to add printing capabilities
for nearly any type of content,
from local images and documents
to network data or anything
that you can render to a canvas.
Android uses PDF as its primary
file format for printing,
so it's best practice to use the
helper classes to print bitmaps
or to generate a
properly paginated PDF
version of your content.
For convenience,
the printing API
provides native
and WebView helpers
to let you create PDFs using
standard Android drawing APIs.
If your app knows how
to draw the content,
it can create a PDF
for printing it.
Nazmul Idris summarizes
the best practices
for getting started
with printing on Android
in this DevByte.
KitKat also introduces new
ways to improve the power use
profile of device
sensors, starting
with sensor batching,
a new optimization
that delivers sensor
results in batches
rather than as
they are detected.
This lets the
application processors
stay in a low-power state
until each batch is delivered.
You can define the interval
at which you receive batches
or request immediate delivery
of events between batch cycles.
There's also two new composite
sensors-- step detection
and step counting--
both of which
were implemented within hardware
to help minimize the associated
power consumption.
And that's just a small taste
of the new APIs available.
There's also a completely
new implementation
of WebView based on
Google Chromium that
offers the latest in
standard support performance
and compatibility,
and most of the HTML5
features available in Chrome
for Android version 30,
plus an updated
JavaScript V8 engine.
There's also a range of new APIs
to better support RTL locales,
including drawable,
mirroring, and pseudo-locales.
Declaring a drawable
as auto-mirrorable
will allow the system
to flip it automatically
for users using an RTL
locale, preventing you
from having to
duplicate your assets.
Android now also includes
an RTL pseudo-locale
as a new developer option.
The pseudo-locale
switches the device
to an RTL for all
locales and displays text
in the current language.
This can help you find
layout issues across your app
without having to display
the app in an RTL language
that you may not
be able to read.
There's also good news for fans
of high performance computation
with performance
improvements to render
script and the new ability to
take advantage of render script
directly from your native code.
A new C++ API in the ADK lets
you access the same render
script functionality available
through the framework APIs,
including script intrinsics
and custom kernels.
Last, but by no means
least, is a series
of security
enhancements, including
an update to Android's SELinux
configuration, changing
from permissive to
enforcing, and improved
cryptographic algorithms.
Elliptic Curve Digital
Signature Algorithm support
has been added to the
keystore provider.
And the script key
derivation function
is now implemented to protect
the cryptographic keys used
for full disk encryption.
In entirely related news,
there is a new device
in town with the
launch of the Nexus 5.
Check out Google Play
for all the details
and grab one for
yourself, purely
for development
purposes, of course.
The Android 4.4 SDK is now
available for your downloading
and code updating pleasure
using the SDK manager.
And you can get more details on
all of the new APIs, features,
best practice, and
every other change
at developers.google.com.